leute was geht ist irgendwie verschlafen
aus obwohl ich schon seit eineinhalb
stunden wach bin ich wollte es zwei drei
sachen sagen und zwar der eine andere
wird sicherlich mitbekommen haben dieses
video war gestern schon mal für zwei
stunden online ich muss dazu sagen ich
hab das video komplett selber
geschnitten und dachte mir so alt ist
auf jeden fall ein unterhaltsames video
und ich muss ganz klar einsehen dass ich
da auch irgendwie ein bisschen los war
und vor allem auch respektlos der person
gegenüber der eventuell wirklich dieser
koffer gehört und die dass sie weil weiß
ich nicht ich hab halt echt zum teil so
ein paar sachen gesagt die eigentlich
nicht gehen oder vielleicht auch private
sachen gezeigt die man nicht zeigen
sollte und ich muss sagen ich habe da
überhaupt nicht drüber nachgedacht dann
allerdings die erste kommentare kamen
und ihr geschrieben habe was ich mir so
ganz genau dabei gedacht habe weil sie
das von mir so nicht kennen und
irgendwie halt alles ein bisschen
respektlos über kam habe ich das sofort
eingesehen dachte mir war das geht
wirklich nicht ich habe das video
offline genommen und dachte mir ich kann
da nichts noch übergehen und es ein
bisschen umschneiden ich möchte damit
absolut niemanden verletzen oder
irgendwie bloßstellen auch wenn man
natürlich sagen muss dass die person ja
nicht gezeigt wird trotzdem konnte ich
voll verstehen wenn derjenige dann das
video schaut wo ich dann so alles zeigt
und mich vielleicht auch hier und da ein
bisschen drüber amüsiere dass es einfach
nicht cool ist und ja deswegen habe ich
jetzt alles richtig private
rausgeschnitten und ich glaube das ist
jetzt einfach nur ein ganz entspanntes
unboxing wir schauen da mal rein genau
dafür wollte ich mich auf jeden fall
einmal entschuldigen und da war halt
dummen plan ist es jetzt schickt den
koffer so zurück an diese familie die
geben den dort irgendwo ab trotzdem
werde ich das video und abgespeckte
variante euch dennoch zeigen weil die
chance besteht ja dass derjenige hier
das video schaut ich denke das ist eine
halbwegs gute lösung und ich bin durch
jetzt viel spaß beim video leute heute
wird es glaube ich echt interessant auch
für mich und ich freue mich sehr dass
das funktioniert hat also und zwar leute
eigentlich hat es dadurch jeder
mitbekommen ich habe in der
vergangenheit öfter mal koffer
ersteigert und wieder ausgepackt und die
waren eigentlich immer von ein und
demselben auktionshaus und das war immer
so ein bisschen komisch also ich war mir
auch am ende sicher dass das auf jeden
fall nicht einfach nur sortierte koffer
waren wo jetzt ein iphone ein bisschen
bei herausgenommen wurde sondern dass
sie noch mal wirklich nach sortiert
wurden das sachen hinzugeben wurden die
gar nicht da drin waren und keine ahnung
ist walter komisch weil so verlorene
koffer von wirklichen personen sind
meiner meinung nach anders aus und
deswegen habe ich immer geschaut wo
kriegt man denn so ein koffer herr der
wirklich einfach verloren wurde ohne
dass jemals wir drüber geschaut hat
aktuell gehen an den flughäfen wieder
sehr viele koffer verloren oder stehen
da einfach rum ich war gestern noch am
flughafen aber da will ich dann auch
nicht einfach einen clown und deswegen
hat mir vor einiger zeit oder ist es
cool dass es passiert ist eine familie
geschrieben das wollt ihr euch einmal
vorlesen ich habe nämlich einen koffer
bekommen wer wirklich gefunden wurde und
wohl noch niemand so etwas rausgenommen
und der ist jetzt auch angekommen und
ich zeige euch mal was sie mir
geschrieben haben ich fand das echt
super nett herr alex wir melden uns bei
dir mit einer so glauben wir tollen
video idee mit großem interesse schauen
wir oft gemeinsam deine videos damit
meine ich meine frau und ich und mich
die auch immer die sind oft wirklich
klasse und wir können gut was lachen
auch deine koffer unboxing sind uns
nicht an gang wir waren letztes mit der
regionalbahn in deutschland unterwegs
und haben auf dem rückweg nach mainz
umgebung einen koffer im zugabteil
gefunden der zug war schon sehr leer und
es war recht spät am zielbahnhof wir
wollen sehr ländlich gab es auch kein
fundbüro der deutschen bahn das habe ich
gelesen wurden direkt meine augen ganz
quo also haben wir uns dazu entschieden
den koffer mit zu nehmen und eventuell
den besitzer ausfindig zu machen leider
gibt es keine persönlichen informationen
im inneren des koffers ich kann vorweg
sagen es ist auch kein luxusartikel oder
ipad enthalten das ist natürlich sehr
schade aber gut unsere idee wäre es
jedem koffer zu schicken und vielleicht
kannst du per video ja doch noch einen
besitzer ermitteln wir freuen uns auf
eine antwort lieben gruß wünscht familie
gut schulz dann kann ich ja sagen ist
egal ich habe mich dann bei den gemeldet
mich bedankt und wir haben ein bisschen
hin und her geschrieben die meinten da
ist kann ich jetzt schon vorwegnehmen
wollen eine digitalkamera drin auf der
auch fotos sind aber nicht von personen
und bevor jetzt einige in den
kommentaren sagen dass es durch von
denen ist dass die die nicht abgeben
haben bei irgendeinem fundbüro der
deutschen bahn oder so ich habe zum
beispiel auch schon mal meinen rucksack
verloren und dann tatsächlich über sonja
über so eine annonce da wieder gefunden
da wusste ich allerdings auch genau wo
ich den verloren hab und der zug ist und
auf eine station gefahren und konnte
nicht angeben von da und da und die
hatten keine ahnung wie lange der körper
da schon drin war und haben sich dann
irgendwie dazu entschieden den erstmals
nach hause zu nehmen jetzt bin ich ja da
und ich glaube die chance dass man den
über mich wiederfindet ist ungefähr
gleich hoch wie die über sondern
deutsche bahn gepäck dingen deswegen
schauen wir einfach dass ich bin auf
jeden fall sehr gespannt und jaletzke
und ich glaube leute hier ist der koffer
drin ich guck mal direkt sein
11 fiel vielen dank das ist gestattet
ich bin sehr gespannt
okay er ist ganz schön schwer da ist
tatsächlich also ich muss sagen die
freude ist schon da hier ist jetzt schon
mal nix drin aber dass ich das noch
machen kann bin ich cool also wenn euch
sowas auch mal passiert dass irgendwann
kommt man findet unter den besitzer
nicht ausfindig machen können weil das
ist ja der einzige weg ich an seinem
koffer kommen kann schick mir denn dazu
ich helf super gern dabei also wenn wir
hier die person ausfindig machen können
und ich bin auch noch vorbei bringen
kann nur so dass der volkskongress und
dadurch dass das ding hat deutschen
regionalbahn gefunden wurde ich habe mir
heute jetzt ausnahmsweise doch mal
handschuhe besorgt weil der ja wirklich
wirklich benutzt oder halten fremder
koffer ist ohne sortierung gehe ich auch
mal davon aus dass es einen deutschen
gemacht wir haben hier die marke
expandable weil sie über das die koffer
marke ist und hier ist also ein buntes
band dran habe ich schon reingeguckt
hier war nichts drin hier ist glaube ich
auch nichts drin also für die die es
interessiert ich würde mal schätzen der
koffer liegt zwar 15 kilo cas ist ob er
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger es ist
auf jeden fall kein handgepäcks körper
mehr sondern wirklich so ein größerer
koffer okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit der kleidung an und dann
machen wir ich sehe schon dvds und auch
ganz viele medikamente mal gucken ob wir
irgendwelche drogen drin finden er
wahrscheinlich nicht hier haben wir doch
als erstes ein t shirt von der marke gc
percy super ich werde auch am ende
dieses videos auf jeden fall sonne das
habe ich mal bei worldwide wohnzimmer
gesehen war ganz lustig sein steckbrief
anfertigen von der person wie ich glaube
wie sie heiß was sie so macht weil keine
ahnung das liegt glaube ich lustig so
das ist das erste hängen das jetzt
einfach hier drüber dann haben wir hier
ist auf jeden fall ein benutzter koffer
das merkt man schon riechen tut man es
nicht waren merkt hier sind zwei paar
wie sagt man khakifarbene sorgten bei da
sind auf jeden fall so ein paar spuren
dran da könnte man jetzt vielleicht
hingehen und dann von verschiedensten
orten die bodenbeschaffenheiten prüfen
um dann zu schauen wo genau ist der
boden sowie an diesen socken dann kann
man schauen welche leute da in der
region waren um dann über die hotels
natürlich die person ausfindig zu machen
die eventuellen koffer in der
regionalbahn verloren haben so wir haben
ja hier haben wir auch eine unterhose so
komme das ist nämlich dieses in den
anderen käufern waren halt nie
unterhosen also kann ich mich zumindest
nicht dran erinnern haben eine hose ich
gehe mal davon aus ist auf jeden fall
männer koffer wo sie mit hier hinten
rückt und ich würde auch mal sagen die
person ist auf jeden fall schon über
reißig oder wahrscheinlich sogar über 40
haben wir eine tasche ob ihr eine tasche
mit einem ich glaube hier ist ein laptop
okay das lege ich aber mal zur seite
dann haben wir hier direkt noch eine
champagner- flasche champagner dollar
linde-titel gucke ich mal nach was er
kostet dann kann ja ist ja manchmal
teuer wenn ich euch mal hier ein also
das ist wahrscheinlich ein leckerer
tropfen da hat er sich auch was gefreut
zu hause und dann ist einfach der koffer
karibus hier ist curry wurst drin also
zu hause eine currywurst und hier so
eine schöne champagnerflasche einfach
entspannt und dann koffer weg das muss
man sich wirklich mal vorstellen die
situation wird ja ganz klar so gewesen
sein er fährt mit der regionalbahn nach
hause steigt aus und merkt dann
irgendwann fakt meinen koffer und die
regionalbahn ist sonst weiter geht's
hier haben wir ein weiteres t shirt von
der marke
klockhaus regular fit dann haben wir
hier wahrscheinlich eine sonnenbrille
oder flippig sonnenberg setzt jetzt
einfach mal auf die ist auch schon ein
bisschen in die jahre gekommen an es ist
eine brille ach so es ist keine sonne
das ist eine lesebrille dann hast du
auch noch deine brille verloren aber du
könntest eine brille auf jeden fall mal
putzen weitergeht sie haben wir ganz
viele medikamente hier haben wir die
nächste flippige kurze hose es wird auf
jeden fall denke ich mal ein wärmerer
urlaub gewesen sein weil bis jetzt
hatten wir nur kurze hosen und ihre dass
das auch noch lange wo sie haben wir
auch eine lange hose wobei die ist schon
ein bisschen hipper hier ist nicht so
hier will willi 50plus da kannst du
schon wolken wobei natürlich sehr
dreckig ist nicht das sehr sich das knie
aufgeschürft hat oder so und dann auch
noch den koffer verloren und jetzt wirds
ganz wild hier haben wir die neuen
august sander geklärt also dieser körper
hat bis jetzt absolute al mandeb sie
haben wir noch weitere unterhosen 18
guck mal unbenutzte sorgen sogar zwei
noch eine unterhose und noch eine
unterhose in den unterhemd ich habe es
glaube ich schon in der anmoderation
gesagt und zwar hat mir die familie
holst gesagt dass da eine kamera ist wo
auch fotos drauf zu haben wir auf jeden
fall noch eine rose es ist die vierte
hose dann haben wir hier noch ein hemd
kulturtasche eine ganz ganz brutale
mütze also die ist ja von einem anderen
planeten denke ich auch noch hier drüber
und eine decke hier ist glaube ich die
kamera drin hier haben wir noch
mundschutz und die haben wir noch eine
kulturtasche mit rasierer zahnbürste gb
krems creme sonnencreme und ja wir
schauen hier ist noch kreml juckreiz
stillen das antiallergikum bei
verbrennungen sonnenbrand und
insektenstiche aha das ist natürlich
auch wichtig du nicht dass du dem urlaub
irgendwie da noch kaputt gestochen wird
und dann kein system dabei ok und dann
widmen wir uns jetzt den interessanteren
sachen wir haben ja noch eine decke und
wir haben hier noch kopfhörer von der
marke sennheiser die sind echt gut aus
und sennheiser ist gar nicht so günstige
marke ups hat mit neues kennenzulernen
aber ich mach dir mal an bockey hier tut
sich leider gar nichts hier haben wir 12
3 dvds und zwar in der serie ncis los
angeles staffel 9 und ncis die
achtzehnte staffel 18 staffeln keiner
wie viele staffeln gibt es davon ich
kenne die serie gar nicht ich kann nur
navy cis und dann haben wir hier noch
einen liebesfilm downtown abbey die
hochzeiten ich glaube der willy hat
tatsächlich die dvds mitgenommen um sie
hier auf seinem laptop der ja auch drin
war anzugucken vielleicht der romantisch
sogar am strand wissen dass es ist kein
laptop leute schaut mal es ist ein
tragbarer es also das ist ja wirklich
einfach nur unfassbar dass es so etwas
noch gibt eine tragbare dvd-player hier
kannst du tatsächlich einfach eine dvd
einschieben und dann entspannt am strand
dvd gucken okay hier sind
kabelfernbedienung schaut mal der marke
show hoch wenn er mal gucken ob der
angeht dann schmeißt war damals eine dvd
seien da kann man sogar tv drüberschauen
der sucht jetzt gerade sender oder wie
das ist ja interessant ich wusste gar
nicht dass es so etwas gibt was ist ein
tragbarer fernseher anschauen auch guck
mal hier hast du ganz viele zieht auch
echt gut aus so was ist bestimmt gar
nicht so günstig so kann man hier sind 1
web.de tschuldigung selber vor willi
tabelle was macht ihr damit meine dvds
egal der sucht halt irgendwie sender und
hier haben wir jetzt noch eine kamera in
boss ist denn aqua foto und hier wurde
mir schon gesagt hier sind bilder drauf
und irgendwie see aufnahmen oder so
wunderschön also wirklich tolle
aufnahmen ich glaube ich habe eine gute
idee weil ich weiß ganz genau dass ich
nach diesem video hause nachrichten
bekommen werden ist vielleicht
übertrieben aber da gibt es bestimmt 20
witzig und da draußen die meinen das ist
mein koffer und die einzige möglichkeit
den waren wilfried zu ermitteln ist dass
die person mir sagt was für fotos auf
diesem kamera drauf sind sowie das halt
wirklich auch in polizeilicher arbeit
manchmal gemacht wird ach so haben wir
noch calvin klein sorgen gar nicht
gezeigt ich muss sagen interessant und
ich schaue jetzt mal wer sich meldet
hast du ein foto wenn ich euch trotzdem
jetzt ein von der digitalkamera weil
vielleicht hätte ja die person die mal
dahin fährt oder ihr euch kommt das
bekannt vor oder keine ahnung und wenn
du tatsächlich der koffer besitzer bist
dann schreibt mir gerne eine mail eine
e-mail ist in der video beschreibung
oder per instagram schreiben aber ich
weiß nicht ob du in sahlkamp us musiker
zu sagen wahrscheinlich ist es ein etwas
kürzeres video weil wir hatten jetzt
auch nur einen koffer aber immerhin mal
einen koffer der wirklich original
verloren wurde aber dann macht jetzt ist
das hier fertig ja ja und jetzt kannst
du hier einfach dvd an machen wir das
ding alter das ist ja das macht komische
geräusche so jetzt geht es hier auch
schon los der film cbs home
entertainment ich schon mal vor hallo
der inhalt dieser dvd ist
urheberrechtlich geschützt so genau ich
darf ich ja gar nicht zeigen sonst wird
noch mal ein video gesperrt aber scheint
gut zu funktionieren
leute was soll ich sagen ich bedanke
mich fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn ihr den kennt
schreibt das in die kommentare und ich
würde sagen wir sind schon ganz mal
wieder ab und jetzt sehr gern den kanal
und wie gesagt heute wenn ihr koffer
habt hier irgendwo gefunden habt schickt
die mir gerne würde ich mich freuen drei
leute